welcome to podcast Ville and greetings
and a Happy New Year from the Church of
what's happening now this podcast is
brought to you by my bookie let me tell
you something both seasons here and it's
time to get in on the action with my
bookie are you sick and tired of getting
the runaround when you ask for a payout
sign up at my bookie dot AG today and
get paid fast when you win my bookie is
your hookup for all your betting needs
so go to my bookie AG today and what
they're gonna do is match your deposit
with a 50% bonus use promo code Church
to activate offer visit my bookie AG and
use promo code Church you play you win
you get paid that's the most important
thing let me let you let me let you know
a [ __ ] secret all right you don't
have to be a broke dick for New Year's
New Year's this Sunday you still got
time you know many times I bumped into a
[ __ ] purse two days before New Year's
so could you there's no games tonight
there's bowl games Thursdays and this
bowl game Friday one pick better till
his [ __ ] wig falls off and collect on
[ __ ] Monday and Sunday you get that
little ball and hang out with a little
girl you've been looking at you know I'm
saying freak out or play some Cosby
anyway number two let me tell you
something the year went and went and
whatever the [ __ ] happened happen but to
a teens coming in with a [ __ ] storm
and you want to be ready right you want
your shoes shined you want your [ __ ]
the suit dry-cleaned you want your
eyebrows trimmed your hair done but most
importantly your [ __ ] has to [ __ ]
clean you want it to be @midnight
you want that [ __ ] muffler be shiny
tip-top Magoo this paper I know you wipe
your ass with that [ __ ] petrified
tree but that don't work you know why
cuz bidets are back [ __ ] no [ __ ]
bidet is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it'll clean you ass better than a toilet
paper on the market it uses clean water
to spray your [ __ ] little muffler
providing you with a shower fresh
feeling after every [ __ ] disgusting
[ __ ] that you take your filthy bucket
no more skid marks no more sugar burns
fairies hanging on your [ __ ] ass crack
just to clean this [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] office you understand me
a [ __ ] unclean out of your ass that's
how [ __ ] clean it'll be so go - hello
- she's calm right now and use code
Church for 10% off your audience start
the year off correctly understand me Lee
kick that [ __ ] mule Rudy Sarzo in the
house the Christ killer in the house
what were you telling me now you used to
play this song yeah that was like the
opening song of set number one ladies
night which was usually Tuesday in Miami
free drinks for all the ladies so you
know the ones where the drinking problem
will show up like it first set you know
and what happens is just bunch of chicks
and they start dancing together you know
and a couple of drinks later it got
interesting you know what year was this
about 70 that's when disco 70 71 this
goes sound like it happened almost
overnight you know what Apple was that
all the big dance clubs in New York and
anything that happened in New York in
the summertime by the time the winter
time came a lot of people you know
snowbirds they would migrate to to
Florida Miami so anything that was
happening in New York in the summer it
would reinvent itself in South Florida
in the wintertime so all of a sudden all
you know it wasn't about bands anymore
and if you were a live band you had to
play what was being played and discos
and disco you know this girl means
record vehicle you know places that just
play records you know like DJ's do now
that was you know this is like the
beginning of the DJ basically and chicks
dug that because all they wanted to do
was just drink and dance and not have to
deal with the with the guys like myself
we wanted to pick them up you know we're
just a nuisance to them you know it's
crazy how I saw that the economy did
great over the holidays retail picked up
4% [ __ ] you know [ __ ] online and
picked up 18% Rudy would happen to a bar
business in this country the bar I've
been married for so long from 70 to mid
85 1990
you were you were not seven nights a
week
are you like have you worried I did
anything from 18 to [ __ ] 30 yeah you
were on seven nights a week and then
when you got that girlfriend then you
went out for night yeah but you went out
Monday night for shot because it was
Monday Night Football if you were single
you went to ladies night and then Friday
and Saturday absolutely you know I I
stay at once in a while stay at a
Holiday Inn and how are they ends back
in the day were notorious for happy hour
you know we were you actually you know
you went in and you got some food for
free happy hour
you know they fed you doing happy hour
which is I think it was inventive so
people wouldn't drink and you know like
get off work and kind of like neck go on
the freeway but get a couple of drinks
before you drive you know just to calm
yourself down after a hard day at work
and and they will give you like these
little sausages and you know just like
finger food but when I was a starving
musician she used to live off that [ __ ]
oh my god this is a cheese what's that
what's the spicy cheese that's got the
jalapeno pepper cat pepper jack but Jack
gets old as [ __ ] hard and you'll still
eat 10 pieces like your [ __ ] dollar
ship you don't beat up they'll be tan or
whenever your [ __ ] feet there with
chips on top oh no oh my god days if you
don't have a happy hour believe it or
not you know and were the best happy
hours my mother oh yeah that's how she
transitioned the Irish to accept her I'm
gonna put that bar there in 1958 57 Wow
she had the other Spanish place down the
block from a grammar school so when she
opened up the bar there was a kitchen in
the back and that you know my mother I
take a lot of equalities I like my food
fresh bro
oh my gold food I could taste Oh food
because I don't have it around me
growing up so whenever my mom would make
for lunch she put on the wine on a table
at 5 o'clock it was already cooked
is that on where's New York this was in
unity said your
city okay so all those bus drivers when
I'm in eat lunch
cuz it was across the street from the
bus station I know yeah and then that's
why five o'clock they come in have your
my seat that break cool black beans and
rice Pro when you're white and you eat
those black beans arise you lose your
[ __ ] mind and I remember the projects
were right across on the up from the bus
station by unicity yeah you know they're
gonna line happen yeah this is 39 okay
okay I guess are you talking about the
back end yeah yeah yeah that's New York
Avenue yeah yeah yeah that's New York
Avenue where you go around and on the
corner there see right there my mom had
that bar right down the corner two doors
down was speaking this bakery like it's
I don't eat sweet food because of that
bakery because I used to go home and go
to speaker mints on top a hashaway
chance they had those cookies and the
strawberry shortcake like nobody man
people would you go in and take number
99 and they were up to number two and
everybody was getting a strawberry
shortcake
you can you went to church and these
coasts in those days and stopped at the
bakery that's how I was raised right in
church you went to the bakery
you came home about [ __ ] 10:30 11:00
and then you ate whatever the [ __ ]
strawberry sure not the Cuban side my
white side after my mother died that's
how every [ __ ] body I grew up with
was raised how expensive for drinks back
then cuz that like on a dollar so what
would that be like a five dollar drink
today
I'm like that's like an eight dollar
drink today [ __ ] an $8 cocktail yeah
it's still cheap you can I remember when
I was in high school there was a place
in Nyack New York but on Monday Night
Football didn't give you six bottles of
Bud for a dollar and the place would be
[ __ ] mobbed think about that six
bottles and a bucket for a dollar we'd
sit there with sixteen dollar debt
dollar death we'd have buckets
everywhere we'll eyes down at that
dollar debt then in candy they got you
out ladies night well he's talking about
look all he's talk he's talking about a
time when the alcohol was free to women
no probably from like I told ya there's
any give a [ __ ] of you crashing
if you crash and Ben went into a school
of bus kids I didn't give a [ __ ] that
even claimers he wasn't here he was seen
leaving it we don't give a [ __ ] what you
saw everybody was drunk
how did they remember nothing nobody
gave a [ __ ] in the 70s about that [ __ ]
when I went to when I came around in the
early 80s it was fifty cents a drink for
ladies nights so you just gave a check
to me here's a dollar but knock yourself
out get me in your drink okay
it's two dollars what the [ __ ] is fifty
cents a drink they don't have way these
night no no no that doesn't exist no
more is it honey hour ago I mean every
time I think to drink I'll just be like
why am i I just get a bottle and go home
like a to me there's never been like a
an incentive to go to a bar now when I
was a starving comic in Seattle
McCormack a Schlitz I want to thank you
if anybody knows anybody would call me
the Schmidt's headquarters huh Tom they
kept me in [ __ ] they kept me
approximately cuz from 2:00 to 5:00 and
from 10:00 to close they had to run a
menu cheeseburger fish and chips a soda
a coconut bottle cause little ones $2
apiece to run happy hour but you didn't
give a [ __ ] I need one of those with
water clams on the half shell that's a
happy hour yeah you know if Morton's had
a happy hour from 10:00 to 12:00 I'm
being there for nights a week and they
made like a milkshake like a night night
no shake like with a little bit of vodka
in it
I wasn't like a [ __ ] Coco Loco I'd be
in there four nights a week 415 pounds
I'd be right now I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
happy happy hour and then as I got older
you know kicked the happy hour into
[ __ ] high gear the Sheridan in
Lyndhurst New Jersey by 1985 what they
put out broody would make you [ __ ]
you would kill you pick on a stick
because now the happy hour got popular
so to get people there well why would I
go to your bar we I got the same hotdogs
he held a bun that you got at your
[ __ ] or [ __ ] it I gotta lift my game
up a little bit so they would start
getting like cheesesteaks and cutting
them into little ones and then somebody
[ __ ] just started putting platters
the midwinter Sheridan in 1985 bro that
next would be there
it wasn't even basketball since you guys
would go to hotels
you have just in city that you lived in
just a drink no you found that the word
God listen Wednesday night there's a
happy hour to land her shared in that
[ __ ] rocks five o'clock first time I
went there they had steak Chinese state
like god yeah be for less then no not be
fun let's pick the other one like steak
with broccoli even wrap it with white
rice they would K this [ __ ] every
[ __ ] Wednesday from a different
restaurant [ __ ] I would go there and get
a soda and he like ten plates of food I
was starving and [ __ ] and how I knew
about the place a girl I knew a house
burned down and now insurance to put her
in that hotel and she would call me go I
just saw Lawrence Taylor downstairs come
by you're not gonna believe this place
that was the extension of the our
[ __ ] and then in Boulder that was the
best happy hour Wednesday night they
call the professional night and they
gave away free shrimp a shrimp that you
took it you took a chance eaten but
that's what they were known for if you
ever go to Boulder you gonna want to
broker restaurants oh they don't bring
you bread they bring your shrimp boat
bolder color hell yeah how could they
get the shrimp there I mean it's like
it's no eat that shrimp is like buying a
lottery ticket you're taking your life
in your hands you know saying they got a
lot of boat the reservoir those little
ones with a shell so you had a D Shalem
yeah oh my gosh so they bring you Leigh
Leigh I'm [ __ ] man mercy they'd bring
you a bowl this big the middle will have
red sauce and it would be [ __ ] two
inches of those shrimp peel-and-eat
shrimp on a bed of ice they didn't bring
you bread that's what they brought and
you would sit there with your date dip
dip dip that reminds me of my father
first time he went to Las Vegas the
buffet he never been to a buffet before
Huber's ooh my Cuban at a buffet
although they go crazy and and it's
usually like that you know you're
talking about he'll go to the shrimp the
shrimp ball and that's it load up the
plate with shrimp and he was sit there
and start sweating because he just who
need anymore he was full but it's you
know it's buffet so it's always been
you can sprays me yeah it's the
principle and we can Cubans get mad at
the white people for eating lettuce and
buffet me the Blanco miracle my pink
icicle mean there's Allah
you're Akiko minam I come alone and crab
legs
Katrina shrimp with eyes and missing an
eyeball this [ __ ]
Katrina shrimp but we'll live it like
doctors we don't give a [ __ ] look at
white do it eat the [ __ ] salad [ __ ]
[ __ ] em I'm over eating prime rib that's
crazy
that's the truth yeah that's how we
think [ __ ] no look at that white dude
making toast Rudy said as he came in
he's like the meeting we were talking
about Cuban food he said the media not
your sandwich was because your parents
thought you would like not suffocate
starve to death in the middle of the
night it's a dog world without food so
you know you're gonna starve
so it's so you eat a sandwich before so
that will take care of the of the next
eight hours days I think I should I was
born to be Cuban with God forbid you had
a Cuban grandmother again glad that
you're her grandson but you're her son
son oh so your mother naturally hates
her that bitch's job it's just a fad new
art and she'll tell your mother go [ __ ]
yourself
he's the only one I can tell you're my
lawyer this is between me and my
grandson get the [ __ ] out of the room
I need your mother's look at me like
don't eat that [ __ ] thingy like I'm a
grandma [ __ ] Sally all right grandma oh
my god Cubans grandmothers will kill
your dog now you're bringing
nochebuena yeah no chip wayna in in
Havana
growing up in Havana you know what's a
little kid and and the first sign that
you know it was gonna be a rockin no
chip winner was the sound of the pig
getting slaughtered right any in in the
neighborhood you know we lived in the
middle of Havana and you know you would
go down to like a like a lot like an
empty lot and somebody would slaughter
the pig right there I mean I'm not proud
of that right now that's that's the way
I was raised
that's how and then before you know it
at night they
the whole pig with with a pineapple
whatever Apple in the mouth and he still
has like little hairs on the skin
because they were not able to like shave
it off completely and you just pick the
Rhine pork what I grew up with pork rind
you know stuff that just horrifies me
today but this is this is how the rough
with the fat attached to it oh my god
yeah you chew on that and you chew on
that kid it's horrible my god yes no no
no that I wouldn't even think about it
today horrible you know but that's the
way that we were you know brought up
like that you know it's in my house it
was a ceremony with the pig like it was
a ceremony like since I could remember
it was an L no fur no chair well has New
Year's or the very night it's the 90s
it's Christmassy okay so this is what
they did my ass Shana no they went to
the bar they went into the afternoon to
the store and killed the pig mm-hmm then
went to Marlins Otto's they got the paid
killed and it got delivered to my house
already and then at 3:00 mm-hmm my
mother would come home with her
girlfriends and take the guts out the
whole thing and then lay it on a metal
pan and marinate it but the marination
took 10 hours so they'd snort coke and
drink and marinate the pig and sing
Christmas songs and so while they were
[ __ ] up and make eggnog and [ __ ] when
I would wake up that morning the
Christmas Eve morning they would be
[ __ ] lit they would be lit and they'd
go go and come back on by the time you
get back to the pig will be ready they
would you know marinate that thing
face-fucking how is garlic garlic Momo
is ALM how bad a human refrigerator
smells can you tell people like if you
leave a soda in there and you gotta open
it up even the metal stinks like [ __ ]
garlic and [ __ ] and drink this [ __ ]
soda hell I taste is garlic mo is garlic
inna and that I have agree about yeah
Agata oranges a flower or yeah oh my god
yeah that's the moral that's what gives
it the flavor - yeah yeah yeah and they
would sit there rubbing that
[ __ ] would that freak you out as
a kid seeing a pig like you just learned
about I wouldn't even look at it I
wouldn't even look at it
I wouldn't you want to you better I
would look at it like my mother will go
look at his teeth my [ __ ] [ __ ] my
pants on out of the houses [ __ ] I come
back ten hours later that [ __ ]
was cooked for the gills with his
eyeball still and [ __ ] and now these
like a family recipes like hey that your
mom's have been passing down cookbook I
mean it's just like a Hawaiian luau they
do the same thing right
yeah this has been done by every [ __ ]
nationality oh you know but I'm saying
like okay I'm a [ __ ] like each family
that probably has its own like different
little take on it or because like I
don't know it's kind of cool it's kind
of cool thinking oh I didn't get this
out of a cookbook this is something
that's been that my great-grandpa would
taste it know exactly what the [ __ ] this
is it's handed down generations and they
each have their own [ __ ] [ __ ] way
of doing it you gotta bring the pig in
from the north or something you know
sayin like it's always something like
he's gotta come in through the back door
you gotta drag him to the back door I
can't come into a pig pig can't coming
to the front door he's never coming to
the back door what the [ __ ] are you
talking about doesn't matter we don't
have a back door put them through the
back window like say that you [ __ ]
got a pig committing suicide me I loose
around his neck
cuz you [ __ ] bringing him up to the
fourth floor you [ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy
it's [ __ ] crazy I got away from that
[ __ ] early
I like the fifth grade I was done I was
done with that Cuban [ __ ] I had it I had
had it and then I would avoid all those
things but I would still go to my
mother's ball cuz I'd make money up
there
oh those Cubans are always give you 20s
on the holidays on 50s so I go up there
for a night and walk out of there were
400 for what do you have to do I just
hug people okay just hug them I'm good
to see oh my god you've gotten so big
are you doing great in school yes is 50
and the drunker they got the more jokes
I told him in the more 20s they give me
there was a book that was a couple of
bookies that would come in there that
would go and there were pockets full of
money and I knew it
and I'd hit him up before they left
what's going on don't let me tell you a
joke how much really go away little kid
fifty bank fifty of whatever twenty I
would go home and my mother would tell
me the next day right how much did you
get last night I lied or no [ __ ]
[ __ ] he gave you a hundred he told
me he gave you what was there anything
for New Year's Eve like is this whole
time of year big or is it just Christmas
this is the the Cuban holiday starts on
the 17th of December because they're
saying lazaros birthday traditionally it
just goes it's not about that on
December 7 before it just goes yeah so a
descent December 4th Kings up that kicks
up for about three days two days prior
people get prepped and then once that
cool down the 17th opens up with Saint
Lazare you got any blood in your [ __ ]
range you just keep going till Christmas
[ __ ] day with your kids and then you
go to the 7th of January
Cubans go to a 7th and Leo Manalo ba la
my lord what is that one that means you
get cash on the seventh day I like that
one I think I knew it there's only it's
the day that the wise men arrive ok
and the manger and they give you money
for that they give you money
perfect sense and I'll take it well
that's what the wise men the broad and
frankincense myrrh and some some spices
it's great it really is I miss all that
[ __ ] I don't miss the craziness that
comes with it because that means that
usually a relative comes to stay with
you for 17 days yeah who rat you out
from all you little [ __ ] I'm saying like
they're always up and you come in you
can't come in anymore red eyes cuz don't
catch you because they watch TV in the
living room that's what I hated about
that time of the year they always going
crazy relative that stay with that
success and you guys miss it at all like
you said as Christmas goes by like this
year I started thinking like I miss I
wouldn't saw this thing in Burbank they
were letting a menorah
and I was singing the songs and it just
brought me back for a second to like
being a kid I was like I can see what
the benefit of this is if I miss that I
miss what I just told you because I
didn't appreciate it while I was going
through it
right young Lani I didn't really I
looked at it for something different
than what it was yeah you know but I saw
how much effort my mother put into
December 4th yeah and I saw how much
effort she put into the holidays like
starting at 16 in the second you have to
stay up the third like in my house you
have to stay up low my one on the third
and then you have to stay up till about
1:00 on the 16th but to bring in the
17th yeah then you have to stay up
Christmas New Year's you got to stay up
and what like what is Cuba like during
this time I can only vent even know you
mean now or this four week or Vardy
period no reason have carnivals got now
I call a composer compiled size like the
big parade you know of like floats for a
whole month you know and it was like it
was like the one in your lanes but every
weekend for a whole month
like for them in a row every weekend
which led up to what you're talking
about you know that's the label that's
the only they sent a lot buddy and and
everything yeah but I don't think that
they do that anymore in Cuba I mean
maybe now because you know things might
are changing a little bit they're
improving the conditions but net for the
last 50 years you know how [ __ ] crazy
is that that they can't live the way
they lived on that judge them crazy yeah
I know I have to call my [ __ ] sister
I I don't do it because the conversation
is always painful yeah but you know just
as she had I offered try to come up with
the sponsor for a month she said she was
too old she don't want to do it
yeah so am I gonna don't ya little every
day ago I got a call and I don't [ __ ]
call it because you know when it's just
one of those things that uh just bothers
the [ __ ] out of me
you know I wish were all together I just
saw my other cousin my other cousin came
up about a month ago and sold out the
Teeter on vine mm-hmm Harry there's a
little Cuban band yeah and then my
friend Stacy polka ludos going to New
Year's for Christmas Christmas for New
Year's and she's going to my cousin's
ball or [ __ ] the red so she's gonna say
something Thomas and y'all say hello
long for me I talk them all to a system
I talk to a key so what are you gonna do
you know say yeah the best thing this
week was you're [ __ ] hired guns movie
and [ __ ] oh you got to watch that [ __ ]
yeah what's it twice man it took a while
like I know was that in Sacramento that
weekend I kept trying to go back to the
hotel and watch it well get too stoned
and pass out this yeah there's nothing
worse than watching something when
you're not gonna be attentive no matter
how bad you want to watch it no bad how
bad you've been waiting for it if you
tied the other miss [ __ ] you're not
gonna watch it right in here then you
gonna go to bed no way they even [ __ ]
finish it yeah you still get up again
and have to watch it again so [ __ ] it I
just watch so like six o'clock when
everything was ready I got nice and
stoned and it was a world I knew him I
didn't know it and I know there's more
to that world so much there's so much
more to the hired gun were landing I'm
saying now when you weren't quiet right
you were not a higher no you were part
of that bad no yeah and even when huzi
you were really noisy I was but wife
snakes sort of yes no it was in between
both you know you know the whole term
higher gun basically you know everybody
even the Beatles at one point there were
a hired gun that were hired by this guy
Tony Sheridan and they made a record my
Bonnie lies over the ocean before they
were signed as the Beatles so everybody
has a bit of history Jimi Hendrix was a
hired gun for Little Richard the Isley
Brothers
King Curtis you know
everyone let's Upland jimmy page one of
the most successful studio guitar
players John Paul Jones he was to come a
conductor and a studio musician so
everybody has a bit of history and
people that do it you know let's say
Steve Lukather with Toto
he played on all the Michael Jackson
records while he was still a member of
Toto we are musicians we love to play
anytime that I get a phone call or
nowadays a a text or something you know
somebody asking me hey are you available
and if it sounds like something is gonna
be fun
and quality I'm there because I love to
play it I love to play music you know
I'm one of those guys who's very blessed
that I did not get to have to play the
same twenty songs for the rest of my
life which is what I really wanted to do
but now that I look back and I go man I
know guys who this is all they do they
do these 20 songs for the last thirty
years it's not a whole lot of fun you
know that was one of the things about
the documentary that struck me is that
they weren't negative about it but even
I forget that the name of the person
saying this but they said plan an a was
to be like the headlining band and this
was plan B for him but to me I don't
know the the the hired gun almost seems
a little bit preferable in some ways to
being like the band where you're out
there and and you have to play the same
20 or you you worried about things
selling out like it's a hired gun you're
just going there to play and you're done
yeah that's what it seemed like to me is
that is that you were paid to play and
every all the other stresses were gone
yeah I mean there's some disadvantages
about being a hired gun is because
you're not really part of the usually of
the creative process because he's just
hire after he's been created you know or
even a songs been written you know
really get hired you know to have an
opinion basically you'll get hired
because there's a vision and you are
gonna fulfill that part of the vision
the best to whoever's hire you you know
say okay I have an idea who's gonna be
great for this and you get a call you
know basically but having said that I
being a member of Balak
riot it was really wonderful to be part
of the creative process to that you
really don't get to do that as a hired
gun so it's a hive gun usually you get
hired to go on the road to promote or
anything is good it could be a tour it
could be to play on a record I I play I
play more records nowadays than if every
dam that had before for the simple fact
that I have time the reason why I have
time is because we let's say right now
I'm in the guess who and we do weekends
we go out and play you know Friday
Saturday and Sunday we're not in a bus
traveling around the country we go home
when I go home I played on people's
records either go to the studio or they
send me the tracks and I record them in
my in my home studio very simple back in
the day when it was in in in Whitesnake
let's say we would have four or five at
least four videos on MTV which meant
that every two or three months they put
out a new video which meant that they
extend that your tour we tour for a year
and a half by the time you got off the
road for that tour you're back in to do
pre-production for the next record and
the next tour there was no time to do
anything else for anybody else so wait
does that mean you're on the road
straight for a year and a half yeah what
you will come home every eight weeks for
about a week because because it's done
by legs you would do like like the East
Coast then you took a break because even
even the crew you know do you have to
it's not just a musician is the crew
they need to see their family spend some
time at home you know and then we will
get back together again because again
you don't want to have too much of a
break because if you do you missed the
crew is gonna do something else one week
is enough for them and they start
looking for work you know like so if you
took up like six weeks well you're gonna
lose your your crew your you know right
so you you keep it you keep everybody
busy but sensibly you know a balance it
very it's very small balance but at
least you know nevertheless you'll be
considering everybody's needs
I hear that yeah you're a year and a
half yeah no way why you on the road
will you write it also we they have the
technology that we have nowadays yeah
you come up with ideas and you put them
in you and you're one of those volt
voice voice recorders you know with a
tiny little that's the technology we had
in the 80s this little little cassette
microcassette recorder I mean nowadays
you can actually make a record one of
these things but or an iPad at least you
know you hear like the old Sabbath
albums they were done when they were
touring like the first nor the second
third yeah that was very popular
itay award while they were touring i
played in bands that did that i play
when I play with the Oyster Cult
they used to do sessions during during
the week and go out and during the
weekends and I believe that guess who
did recordings like that
but see I came in right at the very
beginning of the MTV period and those
were massive tours massive it when I was
with Ozzy both blizzard of aahhhs and
diary of a madman were recorded before
Tommy Aldridge and I joined the band
so we tour for blizzard in the United
States and Canada then we took a month
off just one month and regrouped in in
the UK and we went on we went out on
tour for the European and UK leg of
diary of a madman we thing started
touring diary of a madman until December
30 opening night the Cow Palace in San
Francisco in 1981 1981 so in that in 81
we actually we did two tours in 81
back-to-back for two records two
different records Blizzard took a month
off came back in and late October and
started touring and for diary of a
madman and that tour went up went on
until July and then we did a couple of
festivals and then we recorded we
recorded the speak of the devil Black
Sabbath
at the Ritz in New York 1982 and that
was the last show ever did with Ozzie no
[ __ ] yeah two nights of the Ritz I had
that out I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to it I think I had one
cassette I had on cassette in 1983 in
Snowmass Village ISIL isn't palladium
I just now let's say okay like the
biggest story of hired guns ever from me
will I deal in the early on the Eagles
had a lot of people who switched and
left mm-hmm
the guy from total left this guy left
the Eagles yeah some guy didn't really
want to be in the band any longer yeah
he left and then they got a film and the
original crew was like Feldman the
drummer Henley Henley and somebody else
was it
that's the original Feldman that's what
you had Meisner was the bass variety
Meister then he left and and leaden
leaden was the utility guy you play
mandolin you know solo you know yeah he
played like all these names Joe Walsh
Joe Laban when Bernie leaden left Joe
Walsh came in and then Ray and Randy
Mike Smith's last record was Hotel
California
the bass player Dan the bass player from
poco came in the band the Indian is the
Indian another big Indian one since I
can't tell you why yeah I'm the last
time yeah yeah on the last run yeah yeah
the last real yeah
great singer great bass player I mean
from poco poco was a great band
you know I saw I saw them a bunch of
times life is that draw the line poco
poco draw the line
I saw poco open up I think it was either
top poco or Toto open up a Ted Nugent
Aerosmith Frank Marino mahogany rush
yeah toto
yeah yeah yeah poco was the to me the
guy just stood out and polka was
DeYoung was not related to Neil Young
who is it was a steel like steel guitar
player but he stood up he didn't sit
behind the steel you know you got he
played it like like that like Oh like it
was a lap steel but almost like a guitar
he stood up playing it like a guitar any
word the guy was just phenomenal
phenomenal yeah I just the thing that
baffles me the most are your a high gun
you come in you're coming for the tool
to strengthen it let's say you know you
laid the tracks and you come and on a
tour to strengthen the tour that's what
I thought a higher gun was that or that
buy her a gun it's it's it's it's also a
way of networking and create not only
building your resume but your trust
factor that's when people start trusting
you
that's when you start getting like hey
you know we need a guitar player oh yeah
I just finished doing a tour with
so-and-so I mean he was great he was you
know he wasn't tying me he's my bud
let's let's call him up that is how I
get a lot of gigs because people know me
I'm a tour with a lot of people the
reason why I'm in the guess who now is
because I was doing a tour with the Jeff
tape version of Queens Frank and we had
sass Jordan play the part of sister Mary
because we're doing the whole operation
wine crime record and you know we became
buds and when it came time like they you
know the guess who they're looking for a
bass player SATs her husband Derek
Sharpe who is the the singer and I guess
who hey won't you call Rudy if that
wouldn't that happen I would have never
wind up playing with a guesser you know
because it's it's like you know you
don't even have to audition at that
point even though I consider that I
audition personally every single day
every single day I got a show up with my
best game because the day you don't
that's it it's your it's over everything
you've been building all this time but
in the sense of auditioning can this guy
play the songs that's pretty much I'm
past that now it's the point of is
you're gonna fit in at personality
because of course you know you don't
know until you get together and you
spend some time you know on the road
playing the songs and proving yourself
you know you build that trust but at
least the initial the initial thought of
I know this guy I already been with this
guy you know on tour with this guy I
trust him to do the gig you then become
part of a very short list so it
definitely has his benefit of being a a
hired gun that's how I got to get with
Ozzy because Randy knew me from playing
with him in Quiet Riot in the seventies
so and they were looking for somebody
really quickly in LA if it would have
been looking for if they would have been
looking for somebody in London it would
have been a different story because I
know the Ozzy and Sharon knew a hundred
guys that they could have you know
brought in but here they are in Los
Angeles looking for somebody and it's
like they don't know and Randy kept
saying listen everything that you need
that you're looking for all the
qualities Rudy has him you know he's not
gonna be a bad influence on Ozzy
drinking is not an alcoholic is not a
drug addict he's gonna show up do the
games you can depend on him he's gonna
he's gonna play these songs so it was
kind of like the night before I did the
audition I met Ozzy Randy brought me
over to eight so they were staying at
the the Beverly Hilton and we were there
a Trader Vic's
remember Trader Vic's will having pinion
scorpions at Trader Vic's in Ozzy I'm
talking with Ozzy and he goes man just
do me a favor just be able to play
that's it
that's all because I had the gig already
just because Randy had recommended me so
the next day right before I did the
audition I got together with Randy he
showed me you know Lou because I had to
pick it I never heard the songs and like
overnight I was auditioning for this
band you know so Randy you know he run
me through it and okay so I did the
audition and got the gig
and he changed my life I mean really
change your life you know just in a
moment you know and it that could have
been that could have gone the other way
it could have been the moment that you
regret not getting the gig for the rest
of your life but it didn't happen it
went the other way
well look like that that story kind of
freaks me out a little and a little bit
like okay it's one of the coolest things
that you've got to do a you love having
been in Black Sabbath but the only like
one of the main reasons you got it was
cuz you were in the right city like that
absolutely liked it you have to be you
put all this work in and we have to be
personally and you're like oh I just
happen to be in LA have you listened to
99% of these success stories I know
timing is everything but it's not even
timing it's just a lot of I know it's
timing it's everything it wasn't just
being in LA there was a lot of people in
there oh no no you're amazing yeah no no
no there was a lot of people in LA who
were even with a huge resume that
because they were already rock stars
could not be trusted on a rainbow the
rainbow was full of guys like that the
rainbow Bar and Grill in the 70 was full
of guys who did not get anywhere or did
not get they did not get anywhere until
they went to rehab and cleaned
themselves up one thing is to have the
chop so the other thing is to be
dependable right oh absolutely you know
and and that'd be an [ __ ] because you
know we like you I'm not saying that you
got lucky because you obviously put the
work in and you were a talented musician
but in the end I like was a thing that
tipped it over was that you were in the
right place at the right time is
everything it's a good minute which is
looking back at your life and your
successes you at the right place at the
right [ __ ] time but you know what
this is la la if you're gonna be in the
entertainment industry this is at least
back in the 70s and the 80s this was the
only place and I put it this way if I
wanted out of from becoming a rock star
if what I wanted to really achieve was
the lifestyle of somebody who's gonna
drink have a bunch of chicks do a bunch
of blow I would have just stayed in
Miami I already had that it was right
there I already achieved that
I want chicks yeah sure how many chicks
you know every single night just go to
other clubs I'm playing in bars cocaine
the best cocaine came out of Miami or
you know came to Miami alcohol cheap
cars Corvettes whatever you know that's
not I wanted to be I wanted to be a
musician I wanted to be creative I
wanted to be an artist you know and I
being a rock star was not even in my
radar because I didn't even know what
that was what it was like but I knew
what it was like to go to the concert
and see the guys my heroes moved me
emotionally moving a goal [ __ ] I got a
do that I'm a musician I'm halfway there
I'm already playing an instrument but I
want that creative outlet and to get
there it's at the beginning it's a
freaking mystery man you just have no
idea how you're gonna do it you know
it's like you you know when you got into
comedy this you know how to do how to
get there nothing no no nothing
it's a no idea it's a journey I mean and
you're basically blind you're
blindfolded through the whole journey I
mean you could sometimes to cry or even
see in front of you you know you cannot
even see how you gonna survive another
day but you do somehow you know in 1985
I was clean and sober for four days
I got again television business and my
basketball coach in the eighth grade was
a camera guy for this Gold Morning
America all his life he did it for my 40
[ __ ] years Steve Rubell not you and I
called him so much and bother me stop
taking my calls because he's like what
do you want to do not like I don't know
I just want to be get me a job over
there
do you want to carry sets do you want to
be a white guy like I don't know I think
I want to talk to people but if you got
a job carrying things I'll take the job
carrying things you know I just didn't
know where to start you don't know how
to get into something you know and then
it bothered me and I forgot about it for
a while then it bothered me and I forget
about it for a while until one day it
bothered me so much I actually did
something about it
you know that's the way I look at yeah
yeah and that that's your purpose your
purpose in life you know people call it
dreams and LA for some reason there's
been the city where people have a dream
and they come here somehow they just get
here and it's like once they get here is
like it's just a matter of surviving it
so it's it's it's one of the toughest
places to survive but then again unless
you come here you ain't gonna achieve
your purpose you know people call it oh
man you know I got dreams and no no they
might come to you and seem like a dream
because you start getting ideas oh I
want to become an actor I want to become
a comedian we're gonna become a singer a
songwriter whatever a musician and you
must go to LA you must be here this is
what the end of the industry is this way
you gonna audition this is where you're
going to present yourself this is where
you're gonna be hanging out in the
places where all the that people that
make decisions they are you know this
were the agents are your managers
whereas actually it's it's the conduit
to get you from here to there right you
know this is where they're at and these
are the people who are gonna mentor you
and tell you well listen i got these
clients and you know you know they're
for you to become like this my star
clients you have to listen to my advice
you know i'm pretty sure that they do
work with some people like that watch we
mentor you I have and think that for
that and think that I actually listen to
them you know and LA is built on us us
dreamers the dreamers we come here the
people with a purpose the people who
figure out I want to do
this for the rest of my life I came here
alone adi half yeah I have some
girlfriends but it wasn't the type of
relationship that I was gonna drag them
through hell I was ready to drag myself
through hell to get what my purpose my
dream I used to call it a dream now I
realize it's a purpose in life what it
is and I was willing to do you know
within moral you know without a moral
framework because I still have you know
my spirituality and my moral my
religious guidance but within that
framework
I was I was ready to do anything to
survive anything and I did and I did if
I would have had a plan B I would have
never got gotten a slow as I did which
is basically sleeping on somebody's
floor basically you know can't afford
anything what do you want for food at a
time but I did it because I knew I knew
that that was my purpose in life to be a
musician I didn't know how I couldn't
even see how big it was gonna be but I I
could see that it was gonna be big
enough that I could make that my life
journey being a musician and that's you
get to a point that you find that that
purpose that you're willing to fight for
every single day of your life and you
can't give it up because if you do it's
over it's over
and alle know about you but I trouble
are a lot around the country and I meet
people who at one point they have a
purpose they had a dream they had a
dream and you can tell that that dream
the purpose they never really fought for
it and they're beaten down you know and
I have so much respect for anybody who
comes out here and even if you for
example your your family your kids they
are they then come here they were
brought up by you with a purpose with a
dream they have to add in their DNA they
have that you you race them with that
point of view so they are once they find
their purpose they're gonna fight for it
that would be with me I didn't think
Stan that was my purpose my anger they
go I don't know what it was for me I
knew I knew was my Savior but I knew I
didn't really want to pursue it I knew
it was gonna be my Savior we had this
conversation we in that about three
weeks ago I knew it I knew this was the
answer to all my problems and it took me
you're gonna have to get on that [ __ ]
stage no dreaming though I wish no I
want to be this guy I thought I'd get on
stage two or three times maybe four
times no the fifth time Jay Leno walked
in and put me on The Tonight Show that'd
be a star that's my daughter and that
wouldn't have been fun that wouldn't
have been no good that wouldn't have
been good at all
you know I thought that I heard a story
about uh what's his [ __ ] man you know
moonlighting or Bruce Willis Bruce
Willis said he was a bartender he got
discovered well it didn't happen that
way
he went acting classes and the
auditioned and they got [ __ ]
discovered you know we got I got fed
this [ __ ] stories that you you know
uh uh producer went into a bar and saw
Bruce Willis and hired him for a movie
just like that you know I thought that I
thought it was a lottery I always
thought it was a lottery and I didn't
want to believe that you had to work for
it and today I'm happy I fought every
[ __ ] inch it was they playing the
Green Bay Packers in January when the
snow melts and they're getting more snow
now and you're playing in the mud and
you gotta fight for every [ __ ] inch
you know and I didn't have a point I did
have a plan B really the plan B was to
move to New Jersey and sell coke and let
that be my end because I failed at
everything else that was gonna be it
that wasn't a plan B but I don't know I
didn't have the balls execute Plan B I
always knew there was another month let
me give it another month but I never
even wanted to come here really my
purpose was not the company I just
wanted to be a convict I traveled to
head kept his profile very low just made
enough to sweep by maybe do a little
blow and maybe have a piece of [ __ ] car
if I can live in the van like the
wrestler I would have been good that's
all I want that's all I want I
understand I just didn't want to do what
I was doing which is being a criminal
and being in pain all the time but what
you said about the [ __ ] people you
see I can't like three friends now
that I look at and I know they're a
little walk because I grew up with them
and I know that they wanted to do would
be something different than when they
ended up but because of fear or the drug
addiction or kids or whatever excuse
they made up in their head they didn't
get to that next level 10 I'm saying I
feel that too and that's why I do this
podcast and that's why I bust your ball
for the way I do because I wouldn't have
forgiven myself if I would've never come
out states that I would've committed
suicide oh and I love suicidal type of
guy but if I were to woke up on death at
56 and Subway sandwich would a tattoo a
lair I'm talking about I saw a white
snake in 87 I woulda shot myself
well let out myself do you guys think I
don't know that everyone if you put in
the time is gonna make it like don't you
think some people at certain points no
it's not about making it okay it's about
going for whatever your purpose was like
Rudy says going for it whether you fail
what's making it right that's making it
is what it is for you listen right now
Rudy's built his wall on the road would
guess who he's brother over thousands of
[ __ ] musicians he's met everyone gold
out and platinum albums there's a
musician somewhere in st. Louis
that's a great musician really plays
[ __ ] he's in charge of the [ __ ]
the high school music program yeah he
makes hundred sixty thousand eighty
eight he's got a house
yeah and he's very content but he's
probably this time worth of his Rudy is
bass wise and he's very content that's
his purpose
that's his part that's really was let me
ask you guys give this Rudy and I I'm
not asking for a nice right number but
if you wanted to could you just be
retired right now could you do you have
to play music to survive I play right I
couldn't even imagine not playing it's
like it's not even part of my identity
Rudy retire not making music it's like
you might as well just kill me right if
you just retired from the road and
produced would you think of that or no I
I produce basically to produce it you
know I and I I'm a big fan of producers
and my best friends are producers it's a
whole different role the producer is
kind of like overseer I over cereals
almost like it's it's a bit it's like
being a director or being an actor I
like to be a musician that's the same as
an actor would love to be an actor a lot
of a lot of music a lot of actors going
to become directors but I know my
purpose I know my dream you know talking
about the other people that you were
mentioning right the way that I like to
live my life and you know some people
and I used to do this I you should have
like my yearbook photo that's the guy
that I would talk to because that that
guy that geek in the yearbook
invented this is the guy who came up
with this who I am today
this is his idea right you know and I
can show you the photo
I mean it's despicable you know but
nevertheless this is the guy who was
living in Miami with my folks and I was
just you know graduated from high school
I started playing in titty bars and my
and Miami night and I kept saying okay
this is really cool man you got all
these naked chicks around you and you
got free booze and whatever but this is
not this is not the ultimate this is not
your purpose you see you so loads up
when you saw the purple last week that's
your purpose me being a Cuban kid can
you imagine my own Cuban friends used to
tell me you're crazy you're never gonna
be playing with these guys you're
freaking Cuban from Miami and I said
I'll figure it out I am gonna do it I'm
not staying here I left Miami with you
know secure games you know playing disco
or whatever you know and and whatever
entertainment indulgence that I that I
could get with a suitcase and a guitar
and I went around the country for like
two or three years until I wound up in
my in Los Angeles because that was the
final destination you know this is where
the music industry was because I knew
and there was no turning back to Miami I
mean there was no like well I can always
go back to Miami and keep playing the
bars and doing the know this is now what
I'm gonna do so now instead of me
looking at that kid from high school the
yearbook I see myself as a sperm
competing with a million sperms to get
here just like you did just like you did
you were the sperm that beat out all the
other million sperms you're it you made
it congratulations now white what she
what should any one of us give up on our
dreams we [ __ ] just won right
you know you know wait when you were
playing those those bars in Miami were
you I know you proud of yourself we like
I'm doing something like I'm happier
were you not even if we not satisfied at
all it was it was boot camp you knew
there was something more oh yeah that's
the problem and it was that's what I
always show there's got to be something
more okay this camp yeah it was it was
an ageless area education and also you
you get to you find inspiration and
little bit of fear because I was I was
playing the same circuit as Jaco
Pastorius up in Miami and we'll leave
from the devil a terminal cause I mean
these guys are monsters and I'm thinking
if these guys are in my in my hood it's
gotta be a thousand guys like these guys
of course you know I didn't realize
there was two it's only one jackal ever
but nevertheless that will really
inspire you and make you realize how
hard you have to work because even
though music is not competitive a
competition sport the business is very
competitive right and to me like I seen
what you're saying sometimes when I see
someone who's that great and it doesn't
make me oh I got work it's like oh I'll
never be that good so why you can't do
that right no because see that person
it's what the person has achieved is the
best that they can be you need to
achieve the best that you can be right
because that's completely there's no
competition in that because the other
person will never be the best you that
you can be no I'm just I'm quiet because
this is what I was talking about with my
therapist today this is uh it's a lot of
times like ever just for me personally
I'll make excuses or I'll see something
oh I can't do this because I'm not gonna
be the best and then something she said
to me she's like there's only one person
who's the best and I never even thought
about that before like I don't know
elegance it's a weird thing to want to
be the best but like just being okay
with working on it I guess being okay
with improving and yeah and growing you
know okay if you if you don't grow you
die you wither away
you disappear not only that you get in a
competition the people that keep
improving are the ones that go beyond
right while you're standing still you
know it's not a matter of just even
standing still if you don't move forward
you're gonna get passed by everybody
else that it's that keeps moving forward
right on you you know see you need to
lose that identity because as long as
you keep telling yourself negative
thoughts
you gotta become bad oh yeah a hundred
percent that's I've been going for like
five or six months and I'm working on it
but it's it's just into it like I don't
know I think what you were saying about
Robert Plant earlier it's like we just
think you just see these people who you
imagine are at the top of their fields
or industries you know like there's no
pot like it's not even them not even
like a dream it's not even a physically
humanly possible thing for me to be the
best editor or the bellick and you're
right you gotta you gotta just focus on
let's say Rudy Sarzo is the best place
plan alone right and I grew up listening
to Rudy growing up as his fan his style
of playing this style of movements yeah
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do that for
10 or 12 years but in that journey I'm
gonna find myself and I'm gonna have
Rudy style it's gonna be a 3d
reversionary style do you follow me as
part of his style in it but it you know
it's been in my identity right
absolutely so it's my identity I'm
putting to that base you know when you
Eric Clapton is a great guitarist and
David Gilmour is a great guitarist but
you blindfold me and I can tell you
after the first three quarters playing
it really that's what they do
yeah okay that's what they yeah that's
what they do do you think that they were
clapped and sat there and I don't
[ __ ] Jimmy Page no Jimmy Page do what
he do you do what you do and that's why
people always say to you the most basic
thing be yourself
that would those two words are so
[ __ ] strong and nobody ever listens
fun because we're sold on everything
else that we see we never give ourselves
enough credit be yourself
you'd be surprised what you have to
offer somebody you'd be [ __ ]
surprised I walk around and I see people
living I had a dear friend that lives
this [ __ ] life and I only grabbed him
by the throat and bang his head because
you
that person and the more you keep living
him to that [ __ ] assumed person the
deeper you're gonna get as a human being
as you sup he's never gonna move forward
once I came to terms of who I was I was
a [ __ ] junkie it was fat but what the
prison this is what I'm gonna [ __ ] do
I don't care listen Ralphie may bill
burr louis c.k Rogan Kennison they were
great there are some of the comics I
looked up to but guess what I'm not them
and named me and even though bill burns
the best and Kevin Hart's [ __ ]
tremendous there's a thousand good
comics you figure out somewhere on the
line that you have something to offer
absolutely be yourself
those two words a [ __ ] so gold but we
never have enough confidence and being
ourselves and the timing like the
confidence thing is part of it but it I
don't know for some reason my brain
never even worked that way like and I
never even thought of okay maybe you're
not the best but you cannot like you
have something like that like that
sentence I think is even stronger for me
than to be yourself is like no matter
what level you're at you have something
to offer whether you're just helping
someone you're learning or yeah that
that's that's huge that's great you know
the I I started to improve my playing
once I stopped to trying to be the best
ever
or the best around and I realized that
to focus and to be the best that I can
be the best me rather than the best
overall right yeah buddy because I got
it to it I you know going back to the
question about retiring there's so much
more about music theory and
reharmonization and musing getting into
jazz and all that that I'm doing now
that I know I am NOT going to learn
everything by the time I die or my hands
can move anymore but that's my path I am
you know people ask me you know they say
if you don't know me so what do you do
and I used the the two most powerful
words that I know I am aware I would
even write I'm like like shorting it I
oppose VM I am a musician because it's
not just about playing bass it's about
musical knowledge musical ability and
being able to communicate through music
and listen to others and know what
they're doing and what you can continue
to contribute to the peace you know the
music the composition and that is gonna
take a lifetime and beyond I'll probably
come back reincarnated as a musician and
continue my my musical journey because I
am so in tune with that identity about
myself that to finally after all these
years realize what my purpose is it
wasn't to be just a guy who played in
bars and did this and hung out and you
know played a bunch of music videos know
is about being a musician and I've never
been more fulfilled and more clear about
my life journey that I am right here
sitting with you guys I'm in the same
[ __ ] boat I'm in the same boat
because I'll tell you why bro just today
Josh will call me this morning we'll go
back and forth about [ __ ] and he was
asking me about my schedule I said Liz
left I've been in the ear surgery I'm
not gonna travel for a couple weeks and
then to top it off I'm only going about
one week a month you know wrangly you
don't want problem for 20 years for 15
years nobody talked to me as a comic I
just acted you know yeah that what the
burr crisis for Christmas is dad goes
Enid I saw you want three different
things at the same time you don't like
it no more I go they pulled me into this
[ __ ] stand up and they forget all
about that my point being that I strived
early on not to be the best but to be a
comedian
does that sound that's what my thing was
once I became a stand-up but I started
looking around you know right now
there's this dude that keeps following
me
the last four or five weeks he keeps
calling me he's got a pretty good idea
but you know I won't do it really
because that met him as a comic and the
last ten years he's been four things do
you follow me
mm-hmm he's been four things he's been a
director I've added a producer now he
invented this
I hate those [ __ ] I'm a comic
mm-hmm
I never become anything I want to be a
director no no what the [ __ ] you talking
about I'm a comic you want to make this
[ __ ] project stronger I know how to
do that
I know how to make it funnier from A to
Z I'm a comic I love Brett I'm a great
comedic actor you know when I go all out
of a [ __ ] job now and I got on a set
now it's been 20 years dawg
remember I spent 17 weeks on the set
with Adam Sandler [ __ ] around that's
an experience well he would tell you do
what you want to do really do what I
want to do not what you want me to do so
in 26 years a comic comedy you figure 19
years acting my first three years I was
such a shitty comic do you know why
because I only improvised guess what you
guys have never really seen me improvise
because I don't let nobody see me
improvise even at the store and like I
don't know you see me improvise then
okay but you've never seen me talk to
the audience and do that for an hour
okay I can do that with anybody I can do
that with the best anybody I just don't
do it because it's not Tommy Oh
it creates bad habits it's a bad habit
to get into and then you don't write and
then you keep treating you to do that
and your sets become like raha a dice
control it's a 50/50 set when I get you
I'm gonna [ __ ] get you but if I don't
get you and then trying to get you a
materials for not gonna be a good night
for me so I don't go that route when
people are paying big money for me I
want you to get the best of me you get I
don't want to dick around with you you
wanted missing me [ __ ] around go to
the comedy store right I'll go to the
Icehouse ball I'm getting 25 bucks on me
2750
I gotta go in there by the but not to
take away from what you were saying I
feel the same way Rudy I'm a comedian
bro
and I've studied it I've studied it in
black and white
I've studied it in color I've watched
the combo duo's that they put together
over the years and I did something else
though a lot of people don't do and
forced myself to listen to it instead of
watching it I have always been a
listener that's there's a big difference
than listening to County and watching
comedy and you have to learn how to play
to the listener also at times instead of
the viewer that's another thing people
you know I got good by making people
listen this [ __ ] podcast seven years
of doing a podcast you learned that
people listening to their now watching
here they watch how many videos they
watch a week and if we get 200,000
downloads some people watch it on video
50 60 70 this is basically for people
listening to their car and I've also
loved that like first did this reliever
and Felicia I told them both they kept
saying we'll watch I know I want to take
it back the one people listen it people
don't listen no more or T people wanna
listen no more it's that simple
you know four years in this country MTV
was great because we didn't get to
listen to you it broke that habit we
started watching it watching it yes I am
mmm but to listen you get a different
emotion it's really really we listen to
Richard Pryor watch live on the Sunset
Strip and listen to Richard Pryor
Bicentennial [ __ ] with that album
bouncing and you can hear the waitress
drop in the glasses and all that it
takes you somewhere differently I love
that [ __ ] that's why I love studio tapes
I don't want your album Murray I really
told while you're out I really
what the blizzard of Ozz point the
studio tapes I want to see what you guys
went through how you changed the bass
how Randy changed that solo there's a
you ever see on YouTube when that
[ __ ] do it Joe and Black Sabbath
before dear have you ever heard those
songs you want to shoot yourself and
jump out a window I think it was Ian
Gillan and they have him on this singing
like that happen in Hell oh no no no no
no no they replaced Ozzy before never
say die and then they brought him back
behind his back for Black Sabbath yeah
and they have him singing Junior's eyes
and something else on YouTube
Ian Ian oh it sounds like somebody's
[ __ ] in your [ __ ] hat because yeah
and did the born-again record right
because Quiet Riot open up on that tour
and I gotta tell you I saw him sweating
bullets trying to sing the the iine to
younggu it I mean this guy is he's a
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] I mean he's like one of
them [ __ ] you know that's it
you know he's on that class you know but
he it wasn't him Ozzy is one of the
hardest singers to try to imitate I mean
you know it just no way you're gonna
sound or even deliver it just like Ozzy
the the thing with with Ronnie James Dio
is quality very few people have that
vocal quality but there's something
about Ozzy's voice it's kind of like
Robert Plant the same thing you know
that certain range a certain pitch that
very few people can actually capture
that no matter how much of a
[ __ ] they happen to be in their
own right let me give some shoutouts
here and we'll continue that
conversation because we'll make the
comparison right there for starters the
church wants to welcome this church
wants to tell you Happy New Year from
Rudy the [ __ ] [ __ ] and myself
and all the guests that have come on
here we want to wish you a Happy New
Year
great success to you this year
hopefully you at least go towards your
[ __ ] dream
get off the opioids and make it happen a
little advice to you guys you ready for
this almost 37 years I snorted coke
I think the lat
ever since 1983 I didn't snort coke on
New Year's no more did you know that I
refuse just not talk on New Year's
December 30th
I would snort like I was going to
Pablo's house but on New Year's Eve I
refused to touch cocaine why because
number one I saw my buddy Roger Holloway
get his ear bit off on New Year's 1983
yeah that was one excuse but number two
the real purpose was I didn't wanted him
my system while the year was changing I
always wanted to get away from me so for
you guys that are trying to get off the
drugs don't start on the first start on
the 31st give it a shot take a chance
Columbus did take this from your uncle
Joey all right the big dog
Josh Gallegos Tony Solman swingley 1882
Louie the kid Cody Dunham mr. Wiggles
Matt Brown Sandman and my [ __ ] heart
mr. Bob hula Lingus out there and
[ __ ] Chicago running things
also to my dogs in Austin Texas crystal
and Bob will see you on the 18th when
Lee and I got on to invade [ __ ] cap
city and our boy Danny Brown will be
down there with us that weekend so we're
gonna make Cheney's food - instead of
barbecue yourself just so you know free
[ __ ] I didn't know august 18th
to the 20th Austin Texas the following
Thursday the 25th through the 28th
Charlotte North Carolina to get your
tickets now [ __ ]
what's up Lee I just want to give a
shout out to a buddy on the church page
on Facebook paul vance we talked to him
a couple days ago so yeah poor Vance
there's a behind you now drought I love
you [ __ ] lon Leon you know who
I love ouki spooky Cleo you
[ __ ] are the backbone my little
Indian and [ __ ] whatever the white
chick in Michigan I love you
[ __ ] anyway but take it from my
perspective you know yeah that I
watch your documentary then I watched a
documentary again I found you very
interesting and just real you know just
the way you all hear the hero [ __ ]
tank and it's funny I watched the Ozzie
thing now I was a die-hard Ozzy fan
listen when when my mother died I was
going through all that [ __ ] the song I
was gonna shoot everybody down - it was
sabotage Sabbath playing it [ __ ]
simple you know what's interesting that
in the documentary last night that's our
Sabbath or the night before they
actually showed Tony I only playing the
guitar with his fingers and for years
whenever he took pictures he would never
leave that handout where he had the
accident to cut his fingers but on this
they actually show him with the little
tips that he made to play really
interesting did you watch the
documentary at the end I love them I
love them I loved all that [ __ ] Sabbath
holy Sabbath the sabotage you know
tomorrow's dream when I heard snowblind
that game didn't rain like this nor coke
until we shot Pablo Escobar in the head
I mean you know I don't have to tie end
and I still remember like I told you
going and told magazine store and either
picking up circus look you see or cream
and going Jesus Christ you know how see
is out of Sabitha I had saw what Black
Sabbath and they weren't really that
good Van Halen was on a test of a rumor
was he was gone anyway and you know they
happened to hide the guy from Savoie
Brown to replace him for a while and
nothing really worked out and then we
heard that this dude deal from rainbow
and I already had Rainbow rising like I
already had I thought it was a great
[ __ ] out but I just didn't see it I
just didn't see it I know that's not
gonna work
Black Sabbath the deal is not gonna work
and then I went to a place of the
village the weekend they shot [ __ ]
John Lennon and I saw you guys EP and I
buy my heart almost [ __ ] stop you
know Ozzy's back more than the whole
thing and I think I saw you guys first
at the Palladium yeah but I still want
to see deal yeah
I went to I went to Philadelphia taxes
drove to Philly for the spectrum to see
the electrum deal with Sabbath shakin
Street with Sammy Hagar has a boy sir
Colton that - was that the black and
blue - this was way before the black and
blue toilet was this was the very
beginning of Black Sabbath tour at yeah
then later on they picked up momentum
and went with the black and then they
even made a concert oh yeah I have it
they even made a conscious a lot of
people don't remember I I don't see it
out I don't see it on YouTube
black and blue whatever well I was there
I was there with [ __ ] they were
spitting at Sammy Hagar and Philadelphia
cuz they're their animals now that's why
I love Philadelphia shoutout they were
spitting on their fingers and then go
like this flinging the spit at Sammy
Hagar you could see him singing and
double it like a [ __ ] Anderson silver
and black said well he put his fingers
up like that the first time he's like
generals gathered in their masses just
like Christmas I go we gotta go
my buddy honey - Quayle 88 - its acid
which I have to be - blue quaaludes and
he just passed out in the concert I mean
he was on the floor snoring waking I'm
not where I go wake up until the so he
died we were always go to those [ __ ]
those blue lude you didn't that
Philadelphia they weren't ludes
they were acid you don't [ __ ] I was just
tired for the night before they were
blue ludes that often right but all that
[ __ ] that album grew and me like a
[ __ ] like a herpes crack ho that
[ __ ] boy haven't inhale album it got
stronger by the day and today I listen I
down once a week the whole habitat help
I'm not a fan of the mob rules but I'm a
big fan of heaven that guy took me
little by little it was a very slow
[ __ ] finger in the ass Ronnie James
Dio Sabbath I you know the love I had
for Z transferred right over to whatever
its
I didn't go with any of them because of
the voice it was the belief in their
voice and the convention of what they
were saying that made me believe in Ozzy
Osbourne you know you bastards all that
[ __ ]
I don't think Bo could replace Ozzy and
I don't think Isaac ever plays dear no
they're irreplaceable it's the style and
what they brought to that band did I
know that at 16 and 17 damn really
I was too stupid to figure I figured out
he is later when I saw other singers and
thing of leaving bands and be like I
never I like the first back in black but
by the time for those who Rock who
sucked a [ __ ] came for those who like to
rock came well Rudy I'm not gonna lie to
you you with your popping their binya
yeah that just wasn't me I was a Bon
Scott guy and it was until recently
remember a couple years ago you came in
and you said something funny to me you
got you know what man
I put him a Dane Cook ham in there there
really wasn't that funny was it you that
told me that yeah I loved him in high
school I was really wasn't even how to
turn it off I was so embarrassed that I
liked them that's the way I feel now is
the Motley Crue early motley crew
shouted the devil
I love looks that kill that song makes
me want to snort coke lead somebody's
[ __ ] that soon as that song comes on
and I like the other one a piece of the
action but I gotta tell you son he can't
sing for dick you know that was just
fueled she was it will be the right back
yeah the way HBO they did the rethink of
the Rat Pack and the comedian Bobby
Slade there was more I enjoyed Bishop
set to Dean Martin boy weren't we great
tonight he goes kid relax these days
these people gonna wake up and the
hangovers it'll be over they gonna go
what the [ __ ] was all the commotion
about because it's like we can't we get
caught up in a fog with a lot of music
in our lives
I can't stand [ __ ] a CD sorted by I
think that is terrible between Brian
Johnson and [ __ ]
was the other guy I just talked about
the singer from Motley Crue Vince just
god-awful god off we just got caught in
such a trance
Tommy Lee with the drums and the old guy
sitting there being 90 years old just it
just sucks you in
why was there an old guy there he's part
of the band he's gotta be I don't know
for you if he's [ __ ] everybody else's
50 he's gotta be 18 now what's a guitar
player his name what's his dad make
Marsh big Morris great fun you're
tossing they're being open oh yeah I
said it's a people thing I've seen point
in 1994 in 1984 when I came out that guy
was 50 already the other thing that was
holding them together was the heroin the
scotch tape that's it that was all that
[ __ ] together I just saw him on
the old heavy metal show he could barely
talk I'm thinking of going on tour a
good luck
you gonna what do one show a [ __ ]
week he's an old pro but lady for that
dude I'm telling you but I don't like
[ __ ] none of those things they took
still today at Panaji on and I [ __ ]
love it this morning I listen to my
favorite off diary SAT oh that's my
favorite [ __ ] [ __ ] diary tremendous
on there your tremendous everybody's
[ __ ] sure well I'm not playing with
that record you're not diary and [ __ ]
played on that right oh the same the
same rhythm section that played on the
first record those records were done
back-to-back with within a month of each
other that's crazy yeah it's [ __ ]
crazy you had all those songs yep well
Randy did well now I mean if you look at
the trajectory of that band it was never
the same after Randy died musically
making records it was never the same
never Randy knew how to make make a
record already Randy Randy was very
educated you know about music theory and
Composition which was basically
virtually in very few musicians that I
have ever play with and I'm talking
about the guys like Steve Vai and Tony
MacAlpine who actually got an education
Steve I went to Berkeley you know he
studied music but everybody else that I
play with you know and of course Randy
Rep Randy had music education his mom
his mom won't a music school not too far
from here
you know so it's rain Dinu music just
like any of the top guys you know like
the Jimmy Page you know people like that
he could read he was reading classical
music and writing classical compositions
very rare in the rock world at that time
very very very rare especially the
Sunset Strip bands very rare you know
Eddie Van Halen was another guy that was
schooled in music
he knew he knows you know still with us
you know so and and you can tell by the
quality of their creations of their
compositions the timeless quality of it
because they knew how to incorporate
certain ingredients to make those songs
classics now it seemed I don't know if
it was to me and I hate to say this in a
way but you're right I mean about a
first time I saw Eddie it was a
different type of you talk mmm
you came from somewhere else it wasn't
Michael Schenker anymore yeah yeah
wasn't Tony Iommi it wasn't uh it wasn't
you know Joe Perry this was diesel not
this wasn't David Gilmour yeah it was a
very unorthodox [ __ ] guitar hmm and
then Randy Rhoads took that guitar and
ran with it you know the beginning of
suicide solution mm-hmm that little
guitar thing he does right cuz they do
him before so
[Music]
that you could tell that they came from
different schools and to me the song
diary of a madman itself is right marade
that statement of my thought you love
that that [ __ ] Solo in there right
that's a winner close but diarrhea
[ __ ] madman but no this is uh
this is music 101 today but I'm happy
you came well and even just talked about
it's so hard to understand what your
purpose is mmm what a [ __ ] lousy
thing teenage years was and your early
menarchy not only you figure it out what
you should act like as a man everything
you don't feel got a [ __ ] if you gotta
figure out so much at one time yeah now
to figure out again what your purpose is
yeah because I'll tell you what if you
don't figure it out and you do decide on
something else and eat you alive
then what cat eat you're on those are
the people you see that heavy and they
got on a plane and you let the family
that you can see that the miseries born
out of them you know there's a
difference between success and success
there really isn't financial success and
know what everything you know I could
see the guy that makes a ton of money
like I gotta tell you something at times
I didn't want I didn't want this [ __ ]
Tommy wise it's too much for a guy like
me I love comedy as a hobby you know
saying like I like it as a hobby as much
as the pressure of having to have new
materials and an outlook on life
sometimes I'll dig it sometimes I liked
it when there was just a plain hobby I
liked it when there was just a dream do
you know I'm saying like there's an old
expression sometimes it's better to want
them to have I'm like you now I've
already accepted I'm the comedian I am a
comedian this is what I do for a [ __ ]
living I don't want to direct I don't
want to play the ukulele I don't you
know I like to I'd like again and
writing is a part of this comedian too
you have to write anomaly or whatever
you still have to write there's so many
aspects
to be the musician and a comedian not
just going on stage and performing in
fact the preparation there's so much
preparation to be for that final product
then I wish people would know and the
only way you would know is by doing it
that's the own there's so much
preparation these last three weeks
Rudy haven't thought about dick every
time I think of something funny I push
it out of my head I only want to think
about something funny
I just wanted my mind to breathing it to
cultivate the fall in love with the
arnica but tell me have you watched
other comedians doing that when you when
you take the breather
no I refused I was taking a girl until I
saw stool and watching Rogan just sit in
the back with a mask on but you make a
specific effort because because you know
you you made a choice you make choices
yes and why is that
I wanted I'm doing this from scratch I
don't know if Netflix is gonna give me a
special but if they do I'm starting back
like rocky did I'm going to that fourth
wall every night to do five minutes to
look at young comics eyes to see what
they go for you know you said some very
interesting and I hope this doesn't
offend anybody you know you go to the
rainbow mmm I've been through a rainbow
twice and a lot of times I left they
discussed it mmm because I just saw
people dressed up as musicians then
interesting that's what I saw I didn't
see Rudy Sarzo I didn't see anybody
I didn't even and I how I know that I
did to see her future Rudy Sarzo on
there because of their attitudes mm-hmm
I can't either to see them their eyes I
just saw guys wanted to be Lemmy mmm
that's all every time I go there it's
people wanted to be loving and you know
to be good at this and to be where you
are today you have to be so much in love
of what you're doing it's so
clear-headed that's why you know they
said something very interesting to Tony
Iommi he goes so what do you guys like
now he was or what we did is three days
after the tour ended we all got together
and met in rehearsal one last time
because we never really had to talk on
the tour it wasn't like the old days you
checked into a hotel and went to the
all day and got a habit though eight
o'clock now you have a wife used to look
at things differently and you go to your
room and then a car picks us something
we drive separately to the [ __ ] gig
you know and at times I think that's bad
but at times I think that's great
I don't want to hang out with 20 people
and I do probably I don't want nobody
there I don't want nobody there you know
like it I'm so focused in on whatever I
don't sell t-shirts at my show I could
use the money you can use the money I
don't want to worry about it that in
between shows I want to say hello to a
couple people between shows go back
there and focus on my next show my
breathing and what I got to do one you
know put my feet up so my blood belkin
Goguen
you were saying like there's so much
preparation so uh I don't even know how
we got in this conversation really
doesn't [ __ ] matter this is a
[ __ ] we this tremendously but
I'm really I'm happy that you explain to
these young guys I listen to this
podcast and that everybody does have a
purpose yep you just have to it's not
gonna [ __ ] it knock on your door it
never does no but usually it's that
voice in your head it's that voice in ya
and sometimes you have to like shut the
[ __ ] up and listen to it and those
voices we're gonna give you hints and
ideas and and tell you little things and
once in a while you're gonna connect
with one of them and that's gonna be
your purpose that's gonna be the one
that you're going to wake up every day
of your life and fight for that purpose
oh really you really have three voices
and yet you have the good voice and that
tells you you could do this that you're
better than that guy you know every time
I could tell you why did you become a
comment cuz I was sitting at one line
the comment came on I go hey I'm better
than this guy could do this and the
story you know you have the other voice
that tells you that you'll never amount
to nothing
mmm and you'll never be that good so why
you gonna try it anyway
and then you have the other voice is the
voice of fear mm-hmm that tells you know
what I even thinking about that stay on
the couch hang out on the couch watch TV
sit here with your girlfriend that's
that's it this is what you do you know
what those those last two are there
Billy they're cousins I don't have a
logo yeah yeah I just wanna say just
beat them down yeah yeah eventually we
show up to the neighborhood know
hopefully cuz they know that they're not
gonna win even if they swim up with
somebody that's right even if they team
up with somebody yeah if somebody comes
to me and says hey man I'm having a
[ __ ] party tomorrow night at 8:30 you
gotta be there guess what I got to show
it if you know I'm saying yeah yeah and
that's the correlation you gotta met the
weak side you go [ __ ] comedy you [ __ ]
the show I'll go to a party you saying
that's this idea yeah and then the fear
side here will [ __ ] convince you not
to go to the party for the dumbest
reasons in the world the good voice is
the one that beats everybody yeah yeah
with three or four words you don't even
say much yeah you know that's the voice
that you have to learn to listen to
absolutely and that's the last one we
want to listen to and like for me well
just hearing you guys say that and
what's what I think I need to work on is
realizing which voice is talking to you
because they all sound the same as weird
as that sounds they can all be as
convincing any kind of to are convincing
because that's you know the other to
fear is the most convincing want that
[ __ ] will scare the pants idea
and then your natural voice is the one
that said well you wanna go down for the
rainbow for you what's gonna happen now
there you're gonna bring them in you
gonna go up with you guitar you know do
your two songs for five minutes of peace
and you're gonna go home and in two
weeks you find that that [ __ ] Rudi
was down there rehearsing for his new
band looking for people and you know
when you have a purpose or aka a dream
nothing gets in the way of it and that's
the people that's the problem that
people really really have
that they start letting things get in
the way of it they may in fact they
welcome things getting in the way of it
so I don't have to deal with it there's
so many aspects to just not want to deal
with 2018 I'm happy Rudy even brought
this up we're gonna come on here and
talk about higher guns and how they make
them bigger than to $100 a week in the
megohms [ __ ] sleep in the top bunk is
[ __ ]
we'll talk about that next time because
this conversation try not to be better
because there's a lot of people sitting
in life I think at times I just stuck
and it's not their fault Rudy it's not
their fault
mmm this around they got three people
was stuck next to them
yeah they got this they got that they
got personal guilt I got a little would
take care of my mother your mother's
fine your mother was here 20 30 years
before you got it right it should be 92
years here after your [ __ ] gun you
know we all have these excuses and drop
it just go for is a [ __ ] it's your life
who gives a [ __ ] if you don't do it your
way this is not gonna you know I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm happy I did you know I
was taking this Christmas had a good
Christmas with my daughter she's about
to be five you know we had a great time
but uh a certain Christmas takes out in
my mind the pictures that you saw only
from Christmas 94 when I told me I had
my other daughter the one that's 28 now
the one that we don't talk and and I
thought about that Christmas how I had a
Rob a Christmas tree Rudy had a Rob a
Christmas tree from a lot I've done that
and take the money that people left yeah
so many left cash I took the money and I
came back in here live and pay them back
now I had to put duct tape on that
[ __ ] thing you know yeah and I think
about and this is the truth it goes back
to man on fire I had to give up a life
for a life I gave up being a father so I
can be a comedian it sounds weird does
it sound weird to you and the same thing
I sacrificed yeah for that yeah a lot of
people might say well you walk the
weather and do nothing I paid my child
support check it out go to Kauai give me
the [ __ ] numbers
I tried to be in touch it just didn't
work and at the end of the day now I see
what I see is you know my life for their
life I gave you her life I have I gave
up being a father 20 years ago for this
career of comedy yeah
until this day if I didn't tell you a
pain to be it pains me this time if I
say if I had a second chance I wouldn't
have done even with the things that I
reached the movies and doing TV and the
copy I still say I wasn't worth it but
what would I be today I would still be
stone Koken bald or half dead yeah you
know so yeah I didn't have a child you
know with any of my girlfriends but I
did give up on having a family because
like I mentioned before I don't want to
drag my wife through all the sacrifices
all the [ __ ] that I had to go through
you know to get to where I'm at today I
was gonna do it alone nobody else was
gonna be you know punished by being with
me so I did it by myself you know and 36
years ago Christmas I was sleeping on
the floor I woke up I sang happy
birthday to Jesus that's all I had but I
was bi I was destitute I have any money
related 80 81
no 80 80 80 1980 37 years ago now 37
Christmases ago and I gotta tell you my
gift was peace I've been making peace
with God that I found my purpose I
didn't know how I was gonna it was gonna
wind up happening but at that moment I
was more sure than ever that I was gonna
be a musician for the rest of my life
nothing you know no alternatives no plan
B nothing that was my gift the best gift
I've ever received for Christmas in my
whole life or ever having that peace of
mind with God
and every Christmas I think about that
it's a beautiful thing so serious I
guess Happy New Year do you really have
not watch I had guns on Netflix
you are [ __ ] not getting an education
and it this is coming from a point of
view of someone who's not like a music
fan from all the bands they were
speaking of I found it very interesting
that was a nice thing as [ __ ] yeah is
really interesting that is trending it
was like every night it's like top you
know number one or two most popular and
trending so it must really be connecting
with people out there oh you know know
what anyway I attend this [ __ ]
podcast I can tell you guys the
beginning of the show listen when I was
working for a sports betting service one
December I made a ton of [ __ ] loot
like 60 grand
because Ball Z December is the biggest
month for sports that there is got pro
hoops you have to beginning at college
hoops yeah at the College Bowl you got
pro football playoffs
you got hockey I mean if you're gonna
make a little [ __ ] G this this is
timely and megaguirus
tonight there's a bowl I forget what
bowl is tonight the something bold and
tomorrow night there's another buddy
come on if you're gonna make money Bowl
seasons here it's time to get in on the
action and that's why I'm talking to you
about my bookie
are you sick and time again the
runaround when you ask for your payout
sign up at my bookie dot AG today and
get paid fast when you win my bookie is
your hookup for all your betting needs
and if you can even deposit use you can
even deposit using Bitcoin how's that
beer that's how [ __ ] strong my bookie
is [ __ ]
so where you bet it's just as important
as who or what you're betting on and if
you want to make money betting the ball
games
you gotta go with my bookie dot AG
they're the only site I recommend period
I trust them but you don't have to take
my word for it
check them out yourself they got odds on
every matchup as well as every game live
betting at all this season's NFL and
bowl games but what I'm gonna do is this
for you is this join today today get
ready for this weekend is your [ __ ]
weekend you keep crying you got no money
the suit you want your dicks up but
you're only getting 200 I'm telling you
how to pick up tonight your bet you pick
up [ __ ] Saturday Sunday morning and
you can see the Colombian you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want go to my
bookie and will match your deposit with
up to a 50% bonus you're gonna use promo
code Church CH u CI CH you are CH to
activate this offer when you visit my
bookie IG dot today when you visit my
bookie dot AG today and use promo code
Church you play you win you get paid and
if you're gonna bet this is the only
place to bet my bookie da de Jean
they're gonna get [ __ ] paid
[ __ ] like I told you earlier
listen I know you're setting up your
goals and everything you want a wife
everybody wants this ever he wants that
but then you can sit him what the [ __ ] -
what was the last time you scratch your
[ __ ] balls and sniffed them when was
the last time ladies your finger bang
yourself and smelt that [ __ ] onion
there in the day that onion gets [ __ ]
stinky and so does your nutsack and you
take this [ __ ] you combine everything
guess what it smells like down there a
[ __ ] zoo you don't need that in your
life
what you need is hello - she calm you
like joy what's hello - she
it's a [ __ ] portable birthday that
you see a bunch of them bunch of people
tweeting them yesterday how good and
[ __ ] I mean that beautiful and it
takes 15 minutes you don't even need a
plumber you can do it yourself I did it
myself and I'm a [ __ ] idiot
and guess what happens once you install
this your life will change you won't
leave the house
I won't even see you won't even come on
a podcast no more you'll call up and
I'll go Rudy you're not coming over no
because I'm sitting on my hello [ __ ]
birthday I go what's the rush the way
the way that 20 years time to go get
teeth and get back from you if you want
to clean ass in 2018 it all starts with
a [ __ ] birthday a portable birthday
now you're gonna tell me what Joey I got
toilet paper with and then again on the
side
second side you telling me that your
concern about the rainforest and all
that [ __ ] listen
Toshiba day will clean you guys better
[ __ ] toilet paper on the market and it
uses nice clean water the sprayer but
providing you with a shower fresh
[ __ ] feeling every time you poopy of
it just take your finger yes and touch
the rims is [ __ ] and sniff it and you
like it smells like skin tremendous
that's what you want
and on top of that you'll have no more
skid marks no more dingleberries hanging
from your [ __ ] pubic hairs just an
[ __ ] cleaner than a white [ __ ]
Christmas
they now coming up a little millennial
pink and a blue to add a pop of color to
your bathroom and with two models of
fancy bamboo knobs and they started $69
you understand me
you're gonna sit there and tell me the
yellow LED [ __ ] $69 be the difference
from your [ __ ] smelling like a sewer
then from here [ __ ] smelling like
flowers go - hello - she calm and use
code Church see you see Hur CH and get
10% off your wallet today right now
today and get one for your girlfriend do
you have a smaller [ __ ] at the
[ __ ] three Burger Kings it smells
like [ __ ] debt that's not ever gonna
happen again cuz you're gonna get her
hello - she but day today go - hello -
she calm right now and use promo code
Church to have a cleaner [ __ ] in 2018
and to start in 2018 with a [ __ ] bang
it's my boogie down AG I love youse all
I wish is all [ __ ] the best in 2018
we'll be back Monday nine eight o'clock
ready to rock your [ __ ] world
if you want to know more about Rudy was
there at web page is there
yeah me too find our Facebook Instagram
he's everywhere reach out tell him hello
and ask away if he's planning your town
soon alright I love you [ __ ]
happy new year be safe on new year's eve
and we'll see you back here New Year's
Day eight o'clock tip top Magoo readily
[ __ ] mushrooms acid meshuggenah pills
[ __ ] that stars of that we're gonna
let me he's healing right now Lee and
he's got the bronchitis he's on the
pills but [ __ ] January first will
coming out of here vengeance I love you
guys thank you for all the support in
the love
have a great new year and we'll see you
guys on one day stay black
[Music]